>>> WE HAVE DIGESTED HOURS AND
HOURS AND HOURS OF TV TO BRING
YOU THIS WEEK'S RED NEWS/BLUE
NEWS.
OUR LOOK AT HOW PARTISAN
INDUSTRIES BEND THE STORIES TO
THE RIGHT AND LEFT.
WE'LL HONE IN ON A TOPIC HERE,
ISLAMOPHOBIA.
THINK OF IT AS AIN'T MUSLIM
PREJUDICE.
EXAGGERATED FEAR PERPETUATED BY
NEGATIVE STEREOTYPES.
NOW LET'S GO TO THE TAPE,
TUESDAY, FOX NEWS, HANNITY.
>> WE ARE AWARE OF SEEING
MUSLIMS ON THE MARCH TO IRAQ,
CHAOS ABOUNDS.
HERE WITH ANALYSIS TO THE JIHAD
THAT'S RAGING WORLDWIDE.
>> FOX HANDS OVER ITS MEGAPHONE
TRANSFORMED BY RADICAL ISLAM.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT CHRISTIANS.
>> TOM, LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
MODERATES.
IF THERE IS A MODERATE VOICE OUT
THERE, DO YOU THINK NOW WOULD BE
THE TIME FOR THEM TO SPEAK UP?
>> WE'VE BEEN WAITING FOR THEM
TO SPEAK UP.
>> TOM IS A PROFESSIONAL
COMEDIAN.
HE WAS FILLING IN FOR GREG
GUTFELD, I THINK HE'S FUNNY,
HE'S THE LEAST QUALIFIED TO
COMMENT.
WHY NOT BRING ON AN ACTUAL
MODERATE MUSLIM VOICE AND ASK
THEM.
WASHINGTON POST COLUMNIST DANA
MILLBANK SAID IT TEAMED WITH
ANTIISLAMIST RHETORIC.
A YOUNG MUSLIM STUDENT WHO SPOKE
UP WAS TAUNTED BY THE CROWD.
THERE WAS DEBATE ABOUT WHETHER
HE OVERSTATED THAT, BUT THE
DEBATE DISTRACTED FROM THE VERY
IMPORTANT POINT THE STUDENT WAS
TRYING TO MAKE.
WATCH.
>>> WE PORTRAY ISLAM AND ALL
MUSLIMS AS BAD BUT THERE'S 1.8
MILLION FOLLOWERS OF MUSLIM.
WE HAVE 8 MILLION PLUS MUSLIMS
IN THIS COUNTRY AND I DON'T SEE
THEM REPRESENTED HERE.
>> YES, REPRESENTATION IS THE
ISSUE.
WHETHER THE NEWS IS RED OR BLUE.
SPEAKING OF BLUE, HERE'S MSNBC'S
CHRIS HAYES SAID ABOUT THIS A
DAY LATER.
>> THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS WE
DON'T COVER PEACEFUL MUSLIMS
HANGING OUTGOING ABOUT THEIR DAY
PERFORMING SURGERY BEING
ACCOUNTANTS.
WE COVER ISIS MARCHING THROUGH
WITH BLACK FLAGS LOOKING SUPER
TERRIFIED.
>> WE HAVE THE RED, WE HAVE THE
BLUE.
NOW I WANT TO PURSUE WHAT'S
ACTUALLY TRUE WITH ONE OF CHRIS
HEY'S GUESTS.
WE SAW HER THERE.
LINDA SARSOUR.
SHE'S WITH THE NATIONAL NETWORK
OF ARAB COMMUNITIES.
HERE IN D.C., ONE OF SHAWN
HANNITY'S GUESTS.
SHE'S THE FOUNDER OF ACT FOR
AMERICA.
>> LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT THIS.
THE RADICALS ARE ESTIMATED TO BE
BETWEEN 15 AND 25% ACCORDING TO
ALL INTELLIGENCE SERVICES AROUND
THE WORLD.
THAT LEAVES 75% OF THEM PEACEFUL
PEOPLE.
WHERE DOES THAT STATISTIC COME
FROM?
>> THAT COMES FROM THE COMBINED
INTELLIGENCE OF THE AUSTRALIANS,
GORE DANIANS, THE UNITED STATES.
COUNTRIES ARE MONITORING WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE WORLD.
>> 180 MILLION TO 300 MILLION
MUSLIMS ARE RADICAL?
>> YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THAT
FACTION OUT OF 1.2 BILLION
PEOPLE.
NOW THE MAJORITY OF 1.2 BILLION
PEOPLE ARE PEACEFUL PEOPLE.
THEY ARE NOT STRAPPING BOMBS ON
THEIR BODIES.
THEY ARE NOT GOING OUT BLOWING
UP PEOPLE.
THEY DON'T WANT TO KILL PEOPLE.
>> NOR ARE THE 15 TO 25%.
>> 15 TO 25% ARE RADICALIZED.
NOT EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM
WANTS TO BLOW HIMSELF UP BUT
THEY SUPPORTER OR LISTS WHO WANT
TO BLOW THEMSELVES UP, PROVIDE
THEM WITH FINANCING, MONEY,
LOGISTIC CALL SUPPORT.
>> BRIAN, MISS GABRIEL SPEAKS
OUT OF TWO SIDES OF HER MOUTH.
IN ONE BREATH SHE'LL SAY THE
WEST MUST SUPPORT MODERATE
MUSLIMS AND THE MODERATE MUSLIMS
MUST SPEAK OUT AGAINST TERRORISM
AND IN THE SAME BREATH SHE'LL
SAY PEACEFUL MUSLIMS ARE
IRRELEVANT.
MISS GABRIEL NEEDS TO MAKE UP
HER MIND WHEN IT COMES TO WHAT
IS RADICAL ISLAM.
WHEN ASKED BY AUSTRALIAN NEWS
SHE SAID A RADICAL MUSLIM IS
SOMEONE WHO PRAYS FIVE TIMES A
DAY, SOMEONE WHO BELIEVES IN THE
WORLD OF THE KORAN, SOMEONE WHO
BELIEVES THE PROPHET MAY PEACE
BE ON HIM IS A PERFECT MAN.
THAT'S BASICALLY EVERY MUSLIM.
SO I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT SHE
MEANINGS.
WHERE IS THE ROOM FOR MODERATE
ITS LAMB?
>> WE NEED TO SUPPORT MODERATE
MUSLIMS AND WE WORK WITH THEM.
WE HAVE KEYNOTE SPEAKERS AT OUR
NATIONAL CONFERENCE WHO ARE
MODERATE MUSLIMS.
I HAD A TV SHOW WHERE WE INVITED
THEM TO BE ON OUR TV SHOW.
WE WANT TO EXPOSE THEIR MESSAGE
BUT THAT'S COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
THAN DEALING WITH TERRORISM,
WHAT I DEAL WITH AS A TERRORISM
ANALYST.
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO DISCUSS.
THE MODERATE MUSLIMS, THEY CAN
ORGANIZE.
WHERE ARE THEIR COLLECTIVE
VOICES?
WHERE ARE THE VOICES OF THE
MODERATE MUSLIMS SPEAKING WHEN
GIRLS DISAPPEAR?
>> LINDA, WE HEAR THAT QUITE A
BIT ON FOX NEWS.
WHAT'S THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION?
>> THERE ARE PEOPLE OUT THERE
THAT STOOD UP ON BOKO HARAM, ON
TERRORISM, ON 911.
THERE ARE NATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS
THAT CONTINUED DAY IN AND DAY
OUT TO PUT IN STATEMENTS.
IS THE MEDIA COVERING IT?
I DON'T HAVE CONTROL OVER THE
MEDIA COVERING THESE STORIES.
I DON'T HAVE TO PROVE TO ANYONE
I AM AN AMERICAN BORN AND RAISED
IN BROOKLYN, NEW YORK, AND MY
PARENTS CHOSE TO COME TO THE
UNITED STATES.
AND YOU TALK ABOUT GOING INTO A
GROCERY STORE IN ARLINGTON,
VIRGINIA, BECAUSE YOU SPEAK
ARABIC AND YOU UNDERSTAND THE
CULTURE AND THAT'S WHERE YOU GET
YOUR CREDIBILITY FROM?
I UNDERSTAND THE CULTURE AND I
SPEAK THE LANGUAGE, TOO, AND
I'VE NEVER, EVER WALKED INTO A
GROCERY STORE OR COMMUNITY
CENTER, MOSQUE IN THIS COUNTRY
WHERE PEOPLE WERE SAYING THEY
WANTED TO DESTROY .
>> DeWayne: -- DESTROY AMERICA.
>> RESEARCH AFTER RESEARCH,
THESE ARE FACTUAL RESEARCH THAT
HAVE --
>> ARE YOU A TERRORISM ANALYST
ON TERRORISM IN GENERAL?
WHAT ABOUT THE LOS ANGELES
SHOOTING?
OAK CREEK SHOOTING WHERE WHITE
SPREM MA 'TISES WALKED IN AND
KILLED SIX PEOPLE.
>> TERRORISTS ARE TERRORISTS.
I IMMIGRATED TO THE UNITED
STATES AND I CONTINUE TO HAVE
THE MIDDLE EAST AS MY FOCUS.
THAT'S WHAT I TALK ABOUT.
WE ARE DEALING, LINDA, WITH THE
RADICAL ISLAMIC ELEMENT THAT
WANTS TO WREAK HAVOC ON THE
UNITED STATES.
THERE ARE CARS DRIVING IN NEW
YORK RIGHT NOW FOR BIOLOGICAL OR
CHEMICAL AGENTS IN THE AIR TO
MAKE SURE THAT NOTHING HAS BEEN
DETONATED 24 HOURS A DAY IN NEW
YORK CITY.
IN CHICAGO.
IN MAJOR CITIES IN THE UNITED
STATES.
THAT IS SOMETHING WE NEED TO
DISCUSS.
>> WILL WE NOT LOOK BACK AT THIS
ERA AS A GROWS OVER REACTION TO
A TERRORIST THREAT THAT IS NOT
THERE IN THE WAY YOU'RE
DESCRIBING IT TO BE?
>> THE TERRORIST THREAT HAS BEEN
THERE, BRIAN, FOR YEARS.
AMERICA HAS BEEN ATTACKED UNDER
DIFFERENT ADMINISTRATIONS SIPS
1979 BY RADICAL ISLAMISTS.
>> AND BY PEOPLE WHO HAVE
TWISTED CHRISTIANITY INTO THEIR
OWN BELIEFS AS WELL.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU.
THERE ARE EXTREMISTS ON BOTH
SIDES.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT RADICAL ISLAM,
THE COUNTRY IS SAFE ALL THESE
YEARS SINCE SEPTEMBER 11th
BECAUSE OUR GREAT PROTECTORS AND
FIRST RESPONDERS AND FBI HAVE
PUT PROGRAMS IN PLACE TO PROTECT
US.
THEY ARE WATCHING OVER THE
COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHY WE ARE SAFE.
>> LINDA, DO YOU FEEL THERE ARE
TOO MANY EXAMPLES OF TIMES WHERE
THE MEDIA HAS FANNED THE FLAMES
OF MISUNDERSTANDING ABOUT ISLAM?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
LET'S LOOK AT THE BOSTON
BOMBING.
THE FIRST FRONT PAGE STORY CAME
OUT ON "THE NEW YORK POST" OF
TWO YOUNG ALGERIAN BOYS WITH
BOOK BAGS CALLING THEM THE BAG
MEN.
IMMEDIATELY WHEN SOMETHING
HAPPENS FROM SOMEONE FROM AN
ARAB COUNTRY OF ORIGIN WE
IMMEDIATELY START TALKING ABOUT
TERRORISM AND DOMESTIC
TERRORISM.
THE SAME CASES, SIMILAR CASES,
SHOOTINGS ALMOST EVERY WEEK IN
THIS COUNTRY WHERE DOZENS OF
PEOPLE ARE BEING KILLED AT THE
HANDS OF GUNS AND LAX GUN
CONTROL.
I'M MORE WORRIED ABOUT BEING
SHO
SHOT BY A GUN VERSUS A TERRORIST
ATTACK, AND FOX DOES SHOWS ON
PEOPLE LIKE ME FOR STANDING UP
AND SPEAKING MY MIND AND
PRACTICING MY AMERICAN
PATRIOTISM.
THE MEDIA GIVES THE PLATFORM FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE PSEUDO EXPERTS.
JUST BECAUSE YOU GREW UP IN THE
MIDDLE EAST AND SUPPOSEDLY LIVED
UNDER THE WAR DOESN'T MAKE YOU A
TERRORISM ANALYST.
PEOPLE HAVE HAD TRAINING AND CAN
TALK ABOUT FRINGE ISSUES.
THE FASTEST GROWING RELIGION.
WHAT THEY DON'T SAY IS MANY OF
THE FOILED PLOTS HAVE BEEN
FOILED BY INFORMATION THAT CAME
DIRECTLY FROM THE COMMUNITY, IN
SOME CASES EVEN THE IMMEDIATE
FAMILY MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO WERE
ALLEGED TO BE ORGANIZING A
TERRORIST ATTACK OR TRAVELING TO
PLACES LIKE PAKISTAN AND OTHERS.
>> WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TWO
AMERICANS, HOW WE CAN PROTECT
OUR COUNTRY.
WE ARE BOTH FACED WITH AN ENEMY
WISHING BOTH OUR DESTRUCTION.
WHEN THOSE PEOPLE ATTACK THE
WORLD TRADE CENTER THEY WANTED
TO KILL AMERICANS, MUSLIMS,
CHRISTIANS, EVERYBODY.
WHEN GAZ ZI OR SHA ZAD WANTED TO
BLOW UP TIMES SQUARE OR THE NEW
YORK SUBWAY SYSTEM, THEY WERE
PLANNING ON KILLING AMERICANS,
TEENAGERS, PEOPLE TAKING THE
SUBWAY BACK HOME.
THEY WANTED TO KILL ALL OF US.
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT PLOTS
OF MASS SCALE, SOMEBODY PARKING
A CAR ABOUT TO EXPLODE IN TIMES
SQUARE OR WANT TO BLOW UP THE
SUCK WAY SYSTEM IN NEW YORK OR
WANT TO BLOW UP THE SEARS TOWER
IN CHICAGO, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE MASS KILLINGS OF THOUSANDS
OF AMERICANS IF NOT MILLIONS.
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO BE
DISCUSSING.
>> ISN'T THAT FEAR-MONGERING?
YOU USE THE WORDS THOUSANDS AND
MILLIONS, ISN'T THAT
FEAR-MONGERING?
>> THE IDEA IS YOU WANT TO TALK
ABOUT TERRORISM, LET'S TALK
ABOUT IT AND LET'S BE PREPARED.
LET'S NOT PREPARE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAT ALL TERRORISM THAT
HAPPENS AROUND THE WORLD COMES
FROM THE MUSLIM COMMUNITY.
THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO DEBATE
WITH YOU.
IT'S A SERIOUS ISSUE.
TERRORISM DOES NOT EQUAL ISLAM,
IT DOES NOT EQUAL MUSLIMS.
I AM FROM NEW YORK.
I LIVE IN NEW YORK.
I WAS HERE IN NEW YORK ON 9/11,
MISS GABRIEL.
I UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT THAT
9/11 HAD IN COMMUNITIES.
I COULD BE HERE IN THE WORLD
TRADE CENTER.
75 MUSLIMS DIED IN 9/11
INCLUDING A FIRST RESPONDER.
I WANT YOU TO UNDERSTAND THAT IF
YOU WANT TO COMBAT TERRORISM YOU
NEED TO WORK WITHIN THE MUSLIM
COMMUNITY.
YOU NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE PART OF THAT AND THE QUOTE
MODERATE MUSLIMS WHICH ARE
ALMOST EVERY MUSLIM LIVING HERE
IN THIS COUNTRY NEED TO BE PART
OF THIS DISCUSSION.
TO ALIENATE THE MUSLIM
COMMUNITY, CREATE THEM AS THE
OTHER AND TO START MAKING OVER
EXAGGERATIONS ABOUT THESE
POTENTIAL ATTACKS THAT HAVEN'T
HAPPENED IS NOT THE WAY THAT YOU
COMBAT TERRORISM IN ANY COUNTRY
AND ESPECIALLY NOT HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES IN A COUNTRY WHERE
I CAN LIVE HERE AND SPEAK
FREELY, YOU CAN STAND THERE AND
SPEAK FREELY AND THAT'S THE KIND
OF COUNTRY THAT I WANT TO LIVE
IN AND I WANT TO BE PART OF THE
DISCOURSE.
>> WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
PROTECT THIS COUNTRY AND WE WORK
WITH A LOT OF MODERATE MUSLIMS
WHO SPEAK AT OUR NATIONAL
CONFERENCE.
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT NOW,
ISLAMIC COME MUNITION.
WHEN YOU'RE WATCHING THE NEWS
AND YOU'RE HEARING ABOUT
TERRORISTS IN SYRIA, IN JORDAN,
LEBANON, BOKO HARAM, SUDAN,
NIGERIA, IN CHAD, IN LIBYA, I
CAN GO DOWN THE LIST.
EVERY SINGLE INSTANCE WHEN
YOU'RE WATCHING THE NEWS, IT'S
NOT BUDDHIST TERRORISTS OR
CHRISTIAN TERRORISTS, RIGHT NOW
THE TERRORISM ON THAT SCALE, THE
BODIES PILED UP, THE PEOPLE
BEING BEHEADED, EVEN MUSLIMS
SHOOTING OTHER MUSLIMS.
>> AS LONG AS YOU CLARIFY AND
YOU STAND UP AND SAY THAT THE
FRINGE EXTREMIST OF ANY FAITH
ARE ONLY A TINY MINORITY IN A
LARGER FAITH, THIS IS WHAT WE
WANT YOU TO TALK ABOUT.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT ISLAM AND
YOU TALK ABOUT THE KORAN, 1.4
BILLION PEOPLE ACROSS THE WORLD
FOLLOW THE WORD OF THE KORAN.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU'RE BEING SPECIFIC WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT TERRORISM OF ANY
FAITH BUT MORE SPECIFICALLY
ISLAMIC TERRORISM.
>> THEY'RE NOT WAITING TO HEAR
YOUR OPINION OR MY OPINION, THEY
WANT TO KILL US BOTH AND THIS IS
WHY WE MUST DISCUSS HOW WE CAN
DEFEAT THE RADICALS WHO WANT TO
KILL US, WHO ARE USING THE KORAN
AS THEIR SOURCE AND
JUSTIFICATION FOR THEIR MURDERS.
>> WHY ARE WE HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION IF YOU AND I ARE
IRRELEVANT?
WHY THE DISCOURSE?
WHY THE DEBATE?
WHY THE ANALYSIS.
>> EXACTLY.
WHAT WE NEED TO BE TALKING ABOUT
IS HOW WE CAN DEFEAT THE
RADICALS.
>>> I'M GOING TO WRAP IT THERE.
WE COULD GO ON AND ON.
LINDA AND BRIDGETTE, THANK YOU
BOTH FOR JOINING ME.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>>> THIS IS DEFINITELY NOT THE
LAST TIME WE'LL BE TALKING ABOUT
THIS TOPIC.
I HAVE TO SQUEEZE IN A BREAK
HERE.
WHILE PEOPLE INSIDE THE BELTWAY
CHEERING FOR